because yeah we're in control yeah and  that's what we're saying earlier like to  the the decision to get pregnant is on  the woman it's not on demand like I said  you have you had the access he has to  access your body if it's not great you  once you're once your body is accessed  right you have the decision whether or  not you want to keep the baby after the  baby's born you have the decision  whether or not you want to put the baby  up for adoption or get you it's all on  you but none of that decision would have  existed or been if that joint decision  if you hadn't if a woman hadn't opened  her legs yeah I know can I ask you a  question sorry can I ask you a question  because women women control access to  sex men control access to relationships